all right next snl um had some hilarious
abortion content
on saturday night
it's from the report from the daily
beast it says saturday saturday night
live's weekend update had a lot of
ground to cover this week especially
given that ice cube a celebrity whom
keenan thompson has perfectly
impersonated before lost out on a 9
million active gig in the sony comedy oh
hell no because he refused to get
vaccinated okay but who cares
um
skipping ahead it says the real standout
was and this is an article that's
they're very much impressed with this
bit they're taking a positive view of it
the real standout was guber a clown
played by cecily strong and styled to
look a lot like lunette from the
children's series the big comfy couch
the reason for her appearance to respond
to these stringent texan law that
effectively bans abortion after six
weeks
because just one day before she turned
23 she had a clown abortion
so that's the character she's a clown
who had an abortion
and
this is supposed to be funny
let's watch a little bit and find out if
it is
the supreme court heard arguments this
week in women's whole health v texas
about the controversial texas law that
essentially bans all abortions after
just six weeks here to cheer us up well
this can't be right goober the clown who
had an abortion when she was 23.
[Applause]
so
goober you had an abortion when you were
23. hey whoa slow down i'm a clown let's
clown around hey smell this flower
you're not going to squirt me are you oh
i would never
okay oh gotcha gotcha i had an abortion
the day before my 23rd birthday
okay
it seems like you do want to talk about
your abortion well actually i really
don't but people keep bringing it up so
i gotta keep talking about freaking
abortion but it's a rough subject so
we're gonna do fun clown stuff to make
it more palatable
hey who wants a balloon animal
you want a giraffe
you don't have to do this cecily
i'm goober
and i wish i didn't have to do this
because the abortion i had at 23 is my
personal clown business but that's all
some people in this country want to
discuss all the time even though cloud
abortion was legalized in cloud v wade
in 1973 here
i mean as always with snl the most
offensive thing about it by far
is that it's supposed to be a comedy
show
and it's just not funny at all
i
it's certainly i'd have to acknowledge
there's a real challenge when you're
trying to make a funny joke
about the slaughter of 60 million
children that's not an easy thing to do
i'm not sure that there are any funny
jokes you can make about it
but that definitely wasn't it
um
and in you know we hear from from the
cli the from the goober the clown
this is what we always hear this is the
line we always hear from pro-abortion
especially a feminist well i don't want
to talk about why do you guys keep
talking about abortion
no but but you you do want to talk about
it's all feminists ever do is talk about
their abortions like they want they walk
through the street shouting i got an
abortion everyone i got abortion let me
tell you about my abortion
but then as always if you say well you
know i really don't think you should
have got that abortion that's not a good
thing why are you talking about my
abortion this is my business why are you
so obsessed with it why are you obsessed
with my body
i'm not even i'm not sure even what
point they were
you were trying to reach here because i
take two points away from it from this
bit
one the most direct thing the most
obvious implication here is that
abortion advocates are clowns and i
agree with that
um but then there's also
you know what you find here is this kind
of classic image
of the uh you know the tears of the
clown right
the clown who puts on this kind of wacky
persona and they put the wig on they put
the nose on and everything but they're
hiding their deep despair that's the
classic image of of the clown
and that is in fact
what lots of post-abortive women do
and especially post-board of women who
are shouting their abortions the
feminists the probe the abortion
advocates
okay you spend any time or you go to a
conference of of you know a feminist
conference planned parenthood or
something i wouldn't recommend it
but you're gonna find nothing but the
but goober the clown there a bunch of
goobers running around
all of them talking about how great it
is that they got an abortion how happy
they are about their abortions
isn't it so wonderful
but this is
an act of massive overcompensation
they're trying to hide the the deep
despair and loneliness that they feel
so is that was that the point
is that what they were i don't think
that's what they were reaching for but
that's it's actually a very good point
in some ways it's kind of a powerful bit
but in exactly the opposite way that
they intended
abortion advocates are clowns in general
and yes this is what this is what a lot
of these feminists do
they've got the uh you know it's kind of
like the the classic meme that you see
online of the guy holding up the smiley
mask but behind it he's crying that's
that's it right there
that's that is feminism
especially feminism when it comes to
abortion advocacy
because there's really no way
despite how they try to fool themselves
and and the rationalizations that they
come up with
you know
there's there's just nobody
who especially as they get older and
they get to the end of their life i can
tell you this
there's not a single feminist
on their deathbed who had an abortion or
one or two or three or five abortions or
whatever
who's gonna be lying there on their
deathbed and saying oh man i am so glad
i got that abortion thank god i got that
abortion thank god i'm not leaving any
progeny behind
thank god i'm leaving no legacy thank
god i'm laying here alone
with no one to mourn me
because the only people who would have
mourned me i killed
i can guarantee you there's not one
single feminist saying that
that's all it's always a good litmus
test
it's a good way to decide if you're
making the right choice or not
is to just imagine okay i make this
choice
50 years from now or 60 years from now
hopefully if it's that long and i'm
laying on my deathbed am i going to be
happy
about this choice that i'm making right
now
and if the answer is obviously no
then probably not a good choice to make
you know well there's a a lot of women
who have and it's certainly in the
future
just generations of women who are going
to die alone
with no one to love them
leaving no legacy behind leaving no
imprint on the world at all
[Music]
it's pretty sad that's that is a very
sad thing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated